you know damn it i'm just going to do it
trust some other people you trust people
i never trusted people now i have to and
i want to but
i'm still hard to trust people i find
that i can do most things better
but that's a really i have a saying for
that what
just because it's someone's job doesn't
mean they do it well
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
welcome to the pretty intense podcast on
the show is
jeffrey zarkarian uh he is a tv chef
a regular chef he is you might as well
just call him
his name could have been chef uh jeffrey
grew up in a household where
where all they did was cook i i don't i
don't think he knew any different i
almost think he didn't have a choice
we talked about we talked about cuisine
so he gave some good tips on some of the
hardest
and some of the easiest cuisine to cook
please enjoy
chopped was one of those shows that i
would watch and i literally would just
sit there and just think to myself what
would i do what would i do what would i
do
and then during this break you go up and
get a beer and you come back and like
i can think of what to do but there's no
break yeah you're actually there you
realize it like
that thinking time doesn't happen people
are surprised that it actually happens
on time
i'm like look there's a lot of time
between the courses
but the 20 minutes is the 20 minutes
and you really don't know the
ingredients i thought i saw them
beforehand one time
when i did it i was like i swore i saw
them on a piece of paper i'm like
scallops okay god what am i going to do
with scallops
it's actually better not to see them
i'll tell you why because everyone knows
the person that really is good has a
head up
because they can really might know
something about scallops that you don't
know
so there's a confusion factor that's
always good to have so that first
opening of the body
it really you scramble your brains are
scrambled and you might think you're
making a plan you're not making a plan
you're just pulling them out you start
pans
you on your way to cooking something's
going to hit you and you're going to put
it together in a certain way so i'd say
about seven minutes in
you're like okay i'm going to go in this
direction and then you can change about
10 minutes or 12 minutes but as long as
you are cooking
right away something will come to you
yeah you have to just trust it
yeah if you're cooked that that will
happen it does happen it's called
fear we all have it
we do some people freeze you know they
really they really freeze they freak out
they don't know what to you know they
they
they ha it's almost like they haven't
practiced that critical thinking enough
it's a different kind of it's a
different um
critical thinking in cooking and
competition than it is in life but yes
in life um you know the people that are
most successful i think
in getting what they want to get are the
ones that are
really hooked to failure and love
failure and love the feel of something
that
didn't go quite right there again
so the failure slash practices would you
call them driven then
yes driven it's all a big it's all a big
nut i mean i think my business is like
i'm speaking
for 40 years of experience in my
business uh everyone i know is driven
they're type a they're narcissistic
they're also
sadistic that's sadistic narcissistic
let's add to the list of uh istics here
what else
it's like they don't have some of them
don't have a lot of confidence
self-confidence so they want to please
so they're always trying to please our
[Music]
pleasing business sometimes it is when
chefs are artists when they get
overboard they want to please themselves
but at the end of the day it's business
you need to please the customer you'll
be out of business
that's what we do
is it because everybody's you know like
taste is different because i mean
look if i love something it doesn't mean
you're going to love something but
you're trying to make everyone happy
and every single one of yeah
he them this has this it's like every
day it's an awesome yeah
but they're not coming back if they
don't like it yeah so you have to make
all 300 taste buds happy
that's why sugar works
so you do your best hospitality solves a
lot of issues because
graciousness and being present to
someone who wants you there
and taking care of your needs is it all
saying like
what's your favorite restaurant it's the
one that takes care of you the most
it's true i mean when you talk about
your favorite place
usually if it's like there's one that
may have like magnificent food that
somehow
stands out but generally if you had to
go to one restaurant
you're gonna pick the one where you're
taking care of the best you're the
happiest the people are the friendliest
and you relax and you just like there's
no
it's good vibes and those are the
restaurants that last forever then they
might
seem out of sorts once in a while you
know oh they're kind of old-fashioned
or whatever and then 20 years or 15
years into it they come running back
because our the matridge is great the
drinks are great everyone's kind
they don't say no to a customer there's
no
attitude you know at the end of the day
you know no one wants that
what's the like what's the training for
that what do you tell when to create
that environment are there some cert
there are certain things that
are a directive from top down
what's happening is this today is that
we're talking about getting
more into taking care of the needs of
the employees that the influence the
employees first
so the customers asked for something
special that's like a problem
which is like well let me go see no we
don't do that we can't substitute no
this no that
i mean that's just not it's just that
kind i mean you wouldn't go to someone's
house and say you have a water you know
we don't have water
i'm busy well they don't ask you for a
drink i mean you have to treat people
like you in their home that's a
restaurant i mean it's very simple
and you know if someone says you know i
like salmon but can i have mine well
done well the chef
he thinks that would ruin the salmon so
he's not going to prepare it
probably not going to last but yeah they
will definitely not last
they will definitely not relax maybe
with few exceptions
to people like artisanal pizzas
or small little joints that don't have
the room they're just here it is this is
what it is
yeah and it makes like one thing
but i think that if you're going to a
full-service restaurant you should
you should feel great you go to europe
and you go to some of these restaurants
in hotels
you feel fantastic they just seem to
whatever you want they're getting it's
funny you say that because
they don't work on tips as much there
which is funny like i've always felt
like that in europe when i go so i'm
like
they're just nice it's easy it's
do not make the breezy what makes the
person is their natural born
inclination to be how simple and that
comes from their parents
end of story so i can train anyone in
any one of the
facets of like a thousand employees you
name it i can train it so if you
never wear if you came into my
restaurant and you have great attitude
great respect and you have manners and
you like if something drops on the floor
you pick it up
you know that's a sense of urgency i
cannot teach that
[Music]
yeah true everything else i got you
covered
might take a while like this six months
a year but i got it so that's what we
look for
so we got a bad generation of people
then it's what you're saying if you say
that that well you said
there is people that are gonna
why is it becoming more employee focused
then is that more
than being an employee focused i mean
you know we want to make sure you
respect the
employees yeah yeah of course yeah you
want them to enjoy their
say leave you know you jobs said you're
not welcome here but it's not that it's
against when you sit down you're a
customer mm-hmm
it's not about you it's about the
customer mm-hmm
100 so that customer is home and when
you leave then it's about you when you
leave your shift so i think there's a
that's kind of lost it's a lost our
hospitality
like europe you mentioned about that the
reason why they're there
the hospitality is so great there is
they're they're trained they go to great
schools just great hospitality schools
oh is that a necessity
but we don't have that here we're
starting to what we don't we have
schools
we have you know hospitalities i see
ice in here downtown is great i went to
cia in st helena
for two days i did like a you know a
taste of
taste of california two-day course it's
very luxurious
yeah sure it was we drank and yeah yeah
i mean i
look we we went to an olive oil farm and
we taste all the different
olives we had olive oil cake but it was
pretty educational there was also like
the
effects of salt on food and when to do
it and
you know peppers and spices and how to
test it in a store and how to know what
you're getting
um so yeah it was it was educational but
it was only two days
so you have schools we have schools but
you gotta go to school you gotta get
educated you gotta take apprenticeships
you gotta really learn from a master
whatever that is it has to be something
that is like you evolve into it
and it's a different business this is a
trade it's an incredible trade that you
need to like really love
and be passionate about because it's
just too hard yeah the hours
you know it's just you work morning
night and day
to open a restaurant you know we open
restaurants i'm there when i used to be
there
six months seven days a week breakfast
lunch and dinner just to get
to the stage where like okay seriously
well you go from an indian yeah
you gotta be a five-year-old and like
yeah they're gonna review you
how long does it take for a restaurant
to stand on its own
i don't know yet okay because they're
always
there's always um it you should have it
within a year you're not cash flowing
yeah it's a problem
yeah so meaning you're paying your bills
and even your you like you have a dollar
coming in and you're spending a dollar
if you're flat
that's a good yeah yeah because you're
stabilized i mean yeah
it took 10 years before they started
making money eight years i mean uber is
losing a billion dollars a quarter i
just saw that
and they continue they said we're gonna
have losses for five years okay
so they told the investors they
basically have 20 billion
losses before we start making money so
the gamble is on
getting um uh you know
the rideshare industry and employment
and getting as much as possible
and then raising the rates and they're
all doing the same thing so all the
rates are going to go up
now they're low right so it's the same
as a restaurant business but you really
have
not that much time you have basically a
year to get it together or you can be
sunk
or you're going to put more money into
it so hospitality is key and you're
going to get hospitality right
the tips come later if you don't want to
be in this business you won't be in this
business no matter what you get
you'll hate it if you don't love it and
that's what i try to tell people
so we have people coming all the time to
our restaurant they want to work their
attorney their banker their hedge fund
they want to be the food business
all the time and they know nothing about
food and i actually like those kind of
people
because they know why are they ready for
what why are they over their job and
want to be in that you
it's just it's not path
is there anything about the food about
the food industry that you dread
look there's things about racing i dread
so you know i mean just you you can you
can
you can die quickly in racing we die
over years you know
oh you're slowed up little cuts
like alcohol
it's hard when you're on food all the
time so uh stress a lot of stress
a lot of stress you're a super fit guy
you talked about food but i know you're
super into fitness too well i like
fitness music
i've seen your instagram videos i see
what you're up to you're doing it you're
doing the work
i do the work but that was actually one
of one of some of my
office segments so why don't we show you
at the gym like no that's my
safe space can you leave thank you can't
you leave me alone
you know because there's some people on
instagram they share where they brush
their teeth oh
i get it like i'm not i'm not one of
those people either my kids or like yeah
but she said i said okay just put up
like one
quick video you know none you know
no you know muscle shirt just like a you
know fully like head to toe
no short cut off muscle tank that's next
month
it's in the plan summer's coming
summer's coming so we did one right just
it was like a minute
and it got more hits and it was painting
my food videos
and it was like when i looked at them
i told you i told you you should do this
okay so then what was the conversation
we did one a week and it was called
workout wednesday so we still do it it
still
blows away anything i put on you know
people like bacon and
bacon and eggs and pork and all that
stuff cheeseburgers and
you know food food cells food family and
but fitness is really something i guess
because the juxtaposition of the
business
the chef yeah and working out you would
never it never used to be like that
yeah right paradigm is going to change
you know
the saying never trust this game chef
is now you should always trust the
skinny chef because at least the chef
is maintaining a lifestyle yeah and
allow them to work in a business
they can show you how to eat properly so
you can stay
within your realm whatever you want in a
way that's manageable
yeah i love that that's right it is a
paradigm shift instead of saying like
you have to be fat to be my chef because
that obviously means the food is that
good it's like no you don't give a [ __ ]
no it's well you have to care and
there's no reason
moderation self-respect too right it's
about self-respect
and if it's if you respect yourself
enough you're going to respect me enough
people are fascinated and like really
into it
you know they always ask people how do
you do that
well i mean i i work all the time and
they said when you work i'm like five in
the morning
i would never do that i'm like exactly
that's why you're never gonna do it i
have the same
the saying it's not my saying but i love
it it's if you wanna have something you
you've never had you're gonna have to do
something you've never done that's very
good
so if you look like [ __ ] and you've
never pushed yourself to work out well
that's right where you're gonna stay you
know
you're gonna have to get up at five
it's all uh this business
is year-round breakfast lunch and dinner
everything is free for a shot dangerous
alcohol all the wine all the
socialization yeah
income
so what you have to really learn is that
food is not the enemy
amen i agree i totally agree keep
talking
it is not the enemy there's no such
thing dieting is the enemy
food is not real food's been around
forever those people have been eating
great food full of fat they're in really
good shape and never exercise a day in
their life yeah
you just have to find it you have to
want to do it and if you don't want to
do it you're not going to do it
it's not simplistic but if you just say
well i eat this like that i'm like
okay you know i'm i'm on a like i'm on a
fixed income well who fixed it
you know that's the sort of saying you
have with people they don't understand
that you have to really
take some strides but you just don't
even join them
i completely agree so making food the
enemy and making certain foods in the
enemy is really bad
first it's all little carb then it's all
steak then it's high
it's a bad paradigm then it's like no
it's like a balance i interviewed a
fitness guy and he was like
if you're you know this is what drew me
and why i loved him you'd probably find
him funny he's here in new york and um
i had my own situation where i was like
man it's just i'm doing the work
i eat really i eat uber healthy like i
mean super healthy i mean in my mind
super healthy but then again
10 years ago yours too it's true it's
it's a direct reflection
um and uh and so he was like
if you're not in a caloric deficit you
won't lose weight and i was like
surely i am surely i am surely i am and
then i
finally stopped being an [ __ ] and
making excuses for myself
and i actually counted my calories like
just to really
i didn't know okay this really was 15
minutes and they
they put you in a mask and everything
and you breathe it until it tells you
exactly how many calories you burn
to the calories holy moly they're like
90 percent accurate so
i was like 27 50 or something like that
lucky dog
no but i just
yeah because there's like general math
equations you can do like your body
times
you know 1.2 or you know 1.5 if you work
out rigorously
things like
yeah you shouldn't take in more than 2
000 calories a day
for sure and even that depending on your
bmi and how
metabolically stressed you are and all
that um
it could be more than you need but that
is really about it
is calories in calories it's simple i
tell people like well you know i want to
go
out to drink i'm like this time you can
drink so if you're going to have those
three tequilas
that's 150 calories yeah three glasses
of wine that's 375 calories yeah so if
you have three glasses of wine
in the cheeseburger that's 1200 calories
yeah
yeah that's it yeah so i have one or the
other yeah or i have a half a cheese
yeah and one glass of water
it is just math really simple stuff
to tell people but people don't have the
cheeseburger that's too easy though
no there's got to be another answer
there's got to be a pill i can take
and people make billions of dollars off
of that very
desperation for something outside of
looking at themselves
which is the hardest thing it's a lack
of confidence and lack of like it's just
deflated and they've been told so many
things that aren't true
because there's so much crap there's so
much noise on the internet about weight
loss and food
and i i've seen it all and i'm in the
business work i mean you know if you
watch the food network there's
people eating food that's that great
food okay with this great food too so
you have to understand that they cheer
when butter gets put in i'm like yeah
well that's that's what it has to be i
mean you have to
live in a world that's real living in a
world eating you know
the diets that are out there it's just
not it's not going to be fun for you
you're going to have a miserable
existence
what do you eat god i i have to eat i
taste everything all this yeah so like
i have a fork full of food it's 50
calories sure just so i
just quickly got
so i sit and eat all this food and it's
truly awful
most of it because it's such a hard show
that at seven o'clock when they get like
uh when they open the bag they get lamb
testicles
and they get chocolate i'm not kidding
these are ingredients
and they get a tuna jerky and then black
olives
they gotta make an appetizer and you
like i look at the you know scott and
alex
oh my gosh so it's about
and you eat it cold no they cook it they
cook it we eat it
well yeah but on the show they cook it
but i thought when i was on there what
they said was they take the food and
they set it off to the side
they used to keep it under heaters but
that would affect how much it's cooked
we don't judge on the heat we just judge
in the flavor but so
right right but on top of the testicles
they're cold testicles
courses and two desserts so that's 14
plates of food
and that's and then we wrap at five so
it's a 12 hour day it's a long day
i 100 agree you know say every bite is
80 calories so you add up the bites
you're at
fifteen hundred two thousand cows you
haven't really eaten anything yeah right
when you're hungry yeah and you eat yeah
you're you're over
you're gone you've lost that day yeah
and you can get it back the next day so
that's what people understand yeah if
you have a bad day
you start again in the morning okay
yourself you know i'm gonna start fresh
again
and you will be okay your body doesn't
it doesn't go like this and then go like
this
no one meal no one day no one workout
really even no one week is going to
ever derail your program what i do to
stay away from as much as i can
is white bread white flour
refined sugar okay and i pretty much
eliminated
it from my diet with the exception of
wine which i love which is
sugar it's a carb so i get it so if i
have two glasses of wine it's 250
calories
it comes from a grape absolutely but
it's 300 calories
it's part of it it's part of eating look
there's got to be
some balance and that's where i look i
i'll i'm willing to trade off for a
little bit of wine
i do like dark chocolate me too and
but you know so this is one thing i
don't drink wine
i read you don't have guilty pleasures
and i was like i totally relate to this
because i'm like
i drink a little wine under a little
choc a little chocolate
i you know i i mean maybe i over indulge
in granola and trail mix sometimes but
jesus it's granola and trail mix it's
like paleo granola
and like sugar-free like raw almonds
a slice of cake or slice of pie i have
in the morning
have you want a slice of cake have it in
the morning have fat
they have calories you have grown carbs
but you'll have some coffee and maybe
like uh
you know some milk or something protein
and you'll have eight or nine hundred
calories
but you know what you'll have the entire
day to work that off
if you have that at 10 o'clock at night
after steak dinner you just
you're setting yourself up for failure
and most people have no clue
how to manage their food so they're
managing businesses
bank accounts hr all these complex
instruments hedge funds
sophisticated business staying out of
management all these tools when it comes
to eating what they put in their body
they're like those they're like whack up
they have no idea they just eat
you know and this is like emotional
eating and that's what people like eat
emotional
[Music]
like a coping mechanism for people yeah
so i i don't i try not to do any of the
sugar and i try not to eat
like after seven or eight at night and
if i do it's my smallest meal in a day
if you do that if you do your small
school at night you'll have a chance
yeah a chance at like getting some sort
of equity in your life
which is what you want you should be
losing one pound to two pounds a month
yeah well it takes 3 500 calories to
lose a pound
to be in a deficit of 3 500 calories
um anything other than that if you lose
a pound in a day
it's because of water weight it's
nonsense right it's like when you go out
to dinner and it was like
mexican and maybe you had one tequila
but your dinner was like super salty
it's called water retention watch out
for is mexican which i love
i mean my idea just a cheap there's a
cheat yeah
yeah it's tacos really good homemade
dozen of them what's your is it like so
much calories it's amazing
like short rib are you like a
the second thing is like chinese and
take out all that stuff oh that's a salt
bomb
and sugar it's a sugar salt fat
yeah so you get like a dinner you know
you order in do you think
i'm having chinese it's healthy 2 000
calories
for your portion so it's gonna watch out
i realize that when you when
the fat is the the quickest way to jack
up your calories
that's what i realized when i is like i
would eat like fat i would add fats to a
meal or like eat healthy fats and
they're hell i mean let me give me
almonds and almond butter or like
avocados and
you know like all that stuff and you
think oh you know this stuff is all
really good
fat and more flax and more chia you're
like oh
wait or like the natural like um nut
milks like almond milk or cashew milk
they're wonderful the natural ones are
fine they literally have like the nut
uh filtered water and maybe sea salts or
cinnamon or something they're very
but they have a lot more fat because
they're very very natural they're very
unrefined so
you think you're eating good stuff and
you just start piling it on
and what i realized was holy sh
i've been like eating out of control fat
it's again so
like fat is good you need fat to build
muscle
tear you need it to sustain your body
yeah stay full longer your skin
everything yeah hormones circulation fat
is like amazing but you have to
understand what you have to take in
is a percentage of fat and the
usda triangle is back only
misleading it's wrong yeah okay well
it's humans creating it right so it's
of course it has a potential for flaw
i know it tastes great but it's really
not good yeah
so you should be eating really a lot of
grains minimal amount of
tremendous amount good fats like avocado
lots of fish like fish is one of those
things that simple
they say what can i do what kind of i'm
like okay i have to do this that's what
i said i don't know how i go out i'm
like okay at the end of the day
when you go to a restaurant eat anything
white and green
yeah well yeah i mean even rice is fine
it's like a gluten-free nut okay
okay so fish chicken poultry
duck is okay poultry um all the fish are
white
or and green broccoli broccoli rabe uh
spinach uh
yeah i mean llama fava beans lima beans
peas so at the end of the day if you're
like having a problem just like okay i
want white
so ordered fish everyone has fish
have it grilled and ordered some greens
this is four size water mushroom spinach
size pig yeah last night i had a salad
it was like arugula and some watermelon
actually which
i was like it came out it was watermelon
with some
you know pepitas pumpkin seeds and i was
like oh nice but i was like where's the
green
so they brought me a nice big bowl of
arugula which went great with the
watermelon because of the sweet with the
pepperiness like it was a great balance
and then yeah protein is essential for
you know maintaining muscle and growing
it
will make you full yeah because it takes
longer for your body to break it down
you're going to be bloated you'll be
hungry yeah and then i had tacos with
white fish and i
had one taco one taco with the with the
with it and i was like god that shell
seems like it stays together too well to
be really
all corn so i'm just gonna have the one
and then i just took a fork and ate the
white fish out of the other one
you just have to understand what you're
eating so i think that comes from
cooking though like i always tell
everyone if you want to learn how to eat
out
you need how to learn how to cook in
because if you know how to cook
you know when something is grilled you
know when something's slathered with fat
you know when it has a
boatload of salt on it you know when
something is crispy on the outside
exactly
why like yeah
certain foods fried or okay like certain
foods like french fries they take up
some
more fat than say tempura which is very
quick and it's very light
but it's about how much of that you're
eating in reference to what else you're
having so if you have a big bowl of
french fries
baby that's all you're going to eat for
the day
it's just the calories you can
but you have to recognize what you've
just done yeah what you've just done is
shot yourself in the foot
so you don't want to panic you're like
okay you know what can i split this one
anyway because i really
had so many fries i can't eat it oh i
gotta take this home that's the
sort of rational way to live life it's
called the don't be an [ __ ] way that
my friend jordan was talking about like
you know you know what's right say you
know
we have a problem as a generation i
think right now of denying gratification
we want
right now i don't want to work for 10
years ago i want two years
i want to be on instagram like that
person followers and have like money
coming in
and it just doesn't work you need to put
in the time you need to put in the hours
you need to practice you need to fail
and i said right before like failure is
everything
everything values everything what have
been the most
helpful failures you've had i would say
a marriage gone awry mm-hmm i would say
a couple of restaurants
what happened with the marriage what
let's start with there we were good
friends
yeah we weren't the best of partners
yeah i think we're both like sort of
hiding stuff from each other as far as
not secrets but like we weren't really
really
soulful together but we were really
great friends you still are today
yeah interesting was that because of the
restaurant industry and the
hours or was it just a compatibility
like just no compatibility and you don't
want children yeah that just happens
yeah what'd you learn from it i learned
that
i was impulsive quick to make decisions
and in all facets really helped me
because i i
would like to do stuff and someone
worked 10 hours a day i worked 15 i just
i wasn't maybe not as talented as today
but i worked more
so i just whatever i wanted i just i
went after i got and it was sometimes at
the expense of
either the relationship my soul or my
good standing in my own mind so what
what did you do different after you
realized that then
um
look i think the same things i mean i
can say
i can say i learned and then i'm like
but i'm kind of trying to tell myself
still right now
other people's opinions where i just do
everything myself all the time
you know damn you know you know damn it
i'm just gonna
trust some other people you trust people
a little bit more you delegate a little
bit
and i want more but it's i'm still hard
to trust people i find that i can do
those things better
but that's a really i have a saying for
that what
just because it's someone's job doesn't
mean they do it well that's true
i think that all the time because i'm
like oh my god are you serious
that's you know what it's better to say
that then i'm totally evolved and i
learned that lesson
because the reality is is the lesson's
never over people ask me all the time
how do you balance your
shows on tv production company now
we have qvc we have product we have
consulting business my wife is the
president of it we have three children
under 12.
wow we have four shows wow how do you do
it all how you balance it all like
balance i don't balance anything i'm out
of balance every day
and every day i get up and i'm like okay
where's the worst
part of the equation let's go to that i
knew we were so alike like i'm like
i knew when i met you the first time and
then even like kind of doing a little
bit of reading about you and stuff i'm
like oh my god
i knew we were somewhat kindred spirits
but i totally believe you're right
there's no such thing as balance not for
real there's only balance i call it like
the micro in the macro like the today
right now in this moment something's out
of balance because you're here
and then you get up and you go to the
gym and something's out of balance
because you're doing that and then you
go to work and something's out of bounds
because
you're there and sometimes the the
moments last a little longer maybe it's
a day a whole day maybe it's a week
maybe it's a month
but if you just look at look at like
this wide scope of things
and you go look when i have time i take
it and i dive way into work and i dive
way into my family i end up way into my
wife like
as long as it's like you gotta let what
i say is
everything is it's entropy everything is
you know disintegrating
at a rate at their own rate so i'm
getting older you're getting older that
plant's getting wet
nothing's getting younger you understand
and i mean in a good way
it's all starts and then it just
disintegrates except for george clooney
he seems to never age he's not like that
and you know your wines everything
everything you touch is getting older so
it's all perishing
so you have to like accept that and look
at evolution so i talk about like how is
the day evolving how is our staff
enrolling
how are the problems in our company
involvement we're always going to have
but are they evolving in a healthy way
that everybody's learning how to take
care of themselves and take care of the
problems like
it's going to happen what do we have to
do i'm best when this shit's in the
family you ask anybody who knows me
when everything is oh my god it's like
you know
why because i like it i get calm like
okay
what do we got to do but let's do this
we're going to do this thing and then
we're going to wait and tomorrow we're
going to make another decision we're not
going to make anyone just
this is what's going to happen because
i've seen this show before it's going to
last three months and then everybody's
going to be fine we're going to go crazy
make decisions we shouldn't make today
yeah and that's the way it happens and i
didn't know that 30 years ago
yep i totally agree with that too so i
call it
even though you the thought of like
getting old and everything is like
changing so rapidly but
everybody it's happening at a different
pace so you've got to let people
make their mistake you've got to let
them [ __ ] up yeah
you've got to let them make a mess and
clean it up well because it's the only
so only it's your self-reflection
and your own initiative to change
because of the [ __ ] up that makes you
actually change you're not going to
change because i said
do this and you're like okay it's not
long it's not going to stand yeah right
like
me too i'm a total rebel too
but you have to decide yourself looking
i don't mean people like at the job like
you know i'm just not going to work
today i don't mean those people many
people are aggressively doing stuff so
i i encourage people do it make sure
this is what you're doing make sure you
have an outcome and you have
you have the understanding of how it's
going to happen how it can mess up and
think of it it's going to mess up
anyways
and what do you learn from it so if you
let people do that guess what they get
very like
a bit more granular and they start to
like slow down like okay
that's just to think a bit more and what
do you think of it more you start to not
make
stupid little errors that are like
like those little cuts you mentioned
yeah really sort of add up after a while
yeah it'd be like the go slow to go fast
that i would always tell my pit crew
i was like just slow down so you don't
make a mistake the big mistake is a lot
worse than taking
three tenths of an extra second to make
sure that you get the lug nut on right
okay
yeah well like i don't want you to drop
it because that takes three seconds i
want three
yeah so i i learned to live with it i'm
out of balance
but i know that i'm not bouncing all the
time but if you just accept that and i
don't mean like oh [ __ ] it
i don't mean that at all yeah yeah he's
looking at it all the time and we know
what has to happen we know what we want
to happen but like if you look at the
years
of where six months ago the things that
wouldn't happen a year ago
they're all happening are they happening
on my timetable absolutely not they're
happening because this is when they
should happen ugh
i just knew we were so similar this is
when i was ready for them to happen to
me
and i let them happen to me that's why
they happen
which is really hard so we try not to
compare ourselves
ever to other people like i'm not
comparing myself to
the chef comparison is the thief of joy
he said that's very good i've never
heard that one what instead is
um i read a very good book um
and a gentleman what was it called
jordan peterson what's what's it
called one of the most remarkable books
i've read i've read it three
times oh wow everybody i know and he has
this
12 rules and some of the rules are
craziest like one of the rules is let
escape
let that children skateboard meaning let
them
mess up let them know that i'm spraying
their ankle let them break their neck
yeah and do whatever they have to do
because what they're saying is they're
they're perfecting
their craft they're perfecting their
craft you've got to let people
screw up in practice how long did that
take for you to like
get there i haven't got there yet okay
so
one of the other rules i love is never
compare yourself to someone else
only compare yourself to who you were
yesterday
if you say that a couple times it's kind
of remarkable yes i think it's the
single hardest thing to do in life yes
especially
instagram because the damn instagram all
those hot tricks on there
all those super fit people yeah
successful
yeah you think is real like as
people are aware it's the highlight reel
but we still read into the highlight
reel and we still compare ourselves
and then we get more depressed and guess
what we eat emotionally
we can't handle it there's no way to go
it comes in you're like
really you know you're just like you
feel bad then you you just
still self-immolate you know emotionally
and so
if you kind of figure your life out like
that
every day you just get yourself better
you perfect yourself one day at a time
you get a little better than yesterday
and suddenly
you you say you know what we become
better yeah yeah it's harder
than five years old i used to do that
anymore
i'm barely at a year so what um do you
have like a
i don't know like a self-care program
self-care yeah
physically well there's both right we've
talked about fitness we talked about
food
you know then there's self self care on
the outside you know taking care of
ourselves from the outside in
the best i could still like to drink
an occasional martini so is that a
self-care program from a mental
standpoint of giving yourself
freedom to do the things that you enjoy
that have adverse
effects to what your goal is but the but
the but it
it is outweighed by the enjoyment of it
yeah i
like i mean like self-care like i take
time like my self-care is i work out my
self-care is
i take my dogs for walks in the woods my
self-care is
i you know give myself mantras that help
me with permissions for making mistakes
or other people or judgments on myself
that's important in church every
saturday yeah and i
try to spend as much my kids really
bring me down
and really help me out i ground you yes
i play piano that's a big
de-stressor for me i work out um i eat
i eat in moderation meaning everything
in moderation including moderation
yeah but i when i have a bad day i let
it go and i just get back on the bike
the next day it's not it's not like i
don't i'm not like
i'm not like obsessed yeah people think
i'm obsessed with i have absolutely no
chest i spent 45 minutes a day in the
gym max and not every day maybe
yeah but you can get a lot done in 45
minutes if you actually
work hard like i love when i see
trainers in the gym
and all they're doing is talking i'm
like what are you doing
or texting in between or someone that's
waiting for their trainer
sitting down like i've seen somebody
just sitting there like on their phone
waiting for their trainer i'm like i
don't know hop on the treadmill
start warming up burn a calorie try it
out
[Laughter]
i try to like spend as much time with my
family i'm blessed to have a wife who's
like
like such a such an amazing
um human so honest and so
helpful in all ways and a great mother a
partner right i mean a real partner
yeah you're home you're like you're
sharing business and personal it's very
difficult sometimes
but it works i get it like i've worked
with my parents before and
you know it is hard and then i had to
fire him and that was really hard but
you know it was the best decision i
could make it oh i gave him a lot of
money
yeah yeah i did i did and you know my
goal when i was young was to give my
parents a million dollars
so you know i mean ultimately i mean
they helped me with things but you know
they oh they got there yeah you know i
mean because i paid it forward for you
they did they did and that was my that
was my own personal goal that i set that
i wanted to do
and you understand that you should be
able you have to
look at your kids to take care of your
parents so i tell my kids that you have
to get really good
really smart make sure you do whatever
you do is the best
the best you're like you're the you're
the you're the you're the king or queen
of what you do and then you can do
whatever you want to do
because specialization is really
important it's hard to be a little bit
of everybody
yeah acting yes it's different but and
then you should be able to
you want to take care of the people that
help you which is your friends and your
family i just feel like family i always
say that charity starts at home for me
so it's not just like my parents but oh
what do they support i don't know but i
mean i believe it starts there it starts
with employees it starts with the people
that
i mean shoot someone that's giving me my
facial over tip them you know like
charity starts at home it starts with
the people that help me imagine if we
all just helped
who helped us indeed i
would love to get back to tipping
because sleeping is one of those things
that i think
is it's a polarizing subject
i'm a huge tipper and i don't want to
mean that i have a reputation as you
should
come up with about 100 bills which is
kind of like the old hollywood
[Music]
hundreds of strip bar thing that's not
what i mean what i mean is like i
i love service when service is caring
when they're
helping i mean they're successful maybe
a bad
interaction with what you're doing and
yeah but the service is great
yeah yeah like the person you know about
an airline it's not their fault that the
airline
screw you up yeah and if they really
helped everything they could
well then i either write a letter or if
it's in person i tip because i believe
in that i do it
mostly for myself it makes me feel good
it's like you know what
i know where they're at i know what they
make i know that this is going to help
them and i i don't tip my over tip
and i it's not because i owe it to just
because i want to and i don't overtip
everybody
if i don't get good service i'll tip but
i'm like okay
that was not pleasant you know so i
believe in that i think it's a real
important thing to do
is to really someone once said every
interaction you have with someone anyone
even the people you don't like
be just a little bit kinder than you
have to be
the world will be so much better and i
really believe that
just a little bit tighter some people
make it so hard though i agree i agree i
totally agree with you i mean
you know if we could just give people
the benefit of the doubt though right
like i mean people are probably
you never know what they're struggling
with you know i heard a story the other
day it was something about a
kids are out of control and so it's like
you know something about you know
saying to the dad like get your kids out
of control under control
and he was like we just you know my wife
just died yesterday or something like
we're doing our best and you're like oh
god
and you're just like you never know what
someone is dealing with so
i have a hard time i mean it's something
i struggle with to give people the
benefit of the doubt that they're doing
their best but
that is that is like a mantra i try and
remember is everybody's doing their best
and they're also
they're also only able to
do their best from their own level of
consciousness
and i always i'm worried about blurring
over
15 years 20 years because i always
when someone's quiet i don't say
anything about looking at me in the eye
or there's a problem with a little
squirrel or scruff i i sort of do a
little reverse
psychology i'm like hi what's your name
i i love what you're wearing or
something i just make it
i compliment it break the ice even if
it's not even a compound
chain or like i love it yeah yeah all
those glasses yeah
and like well thank you and i know
enough about stuff i could say that was
that
and all of a sudden the person was like
moody and quiet
maybe it feels bad for their cells
because they're in the job they really
don't respect
they're like you know sweeping a floor
or like you're a pa they're not like
happy
yeah they light up yeah they light up
and never not it never doesn't happen
never
kindness is always welcome it's just
paying attention to someone and you look
in their eye and asking a question and
then when they respond like come back
and like
have something else to say not just like
it's not just
dropping obama and then all of a sudden
that person is a shy person on the
corner is uh
okay he's starting to talk to you and
then on the way out as a different
person
they're like either hi are you okay
great to see you nice to meet you so
nice to chat with you and
when you came in you have this judgment
of people you're like oh that person
looks miserable oh my god
you know stay away from me oh my god
it's easy to do because it's natural
that's what we do you know we judge
everything every day so
that's something i've learned i was
never really good at it and
i've been much better at it i can't say
i'm perfect at it but i can see
i can spot it it's a wonderful habit
immediately
i describe that as like wanting to be
the light of the room i want to be a
light when i come in i want people
to be lifted by me because energies are
real
and you can feel when someone's negative
angry dangerous happy
you can tell uh and so it's
i've all my goal because and it's always
going to be a work in progress i'm
sure but is to be someone that lifts
other people's energies up instead of
being brought down to be so rooted and
protect my own energy so much
and nurture it and create such positive
mental patterns that i stay
in a higher vibrational state more often
that i can help people raise their own
level you know it's like it's like
you have two choices in life really as
you are as an adult
you can choose optimism
this is this this bottle of water here
is not full but i'm going to fill it up
or you can choose pessimism it's not
enough
it's empty and optimism i choose
optimism every time
because i choose to want to be
optimistic and i choose to want to have
good things happen
so when they happen i'm happy yeah in
that stage already if you choose
pessimism you're always thinking
something bad is going to happen and
then when something bad happens
you've already chosen a white stuff now
you have it a second time right
so pessimists you get two waxes yeah
optimism it's just optimistic yeah
if it happens you're like okay yeah
pessimism you're worrying about it
not happening and then it doesn't happen
and you're screwed right i agree
terrible way to go through life i agree
now it doesn't really matter
life is going to be what it is but if
you choose optimism i guarantee you you
will make better choices
you will understand what happens to you
better even if it's bad
and you like look at things sit back and
say okay you know i can handle this this
is fine
it's not exactly what i wanted but we'll
get through it you always get through it
you always get through it i believe and
like attracts like
so you know about the energies and the
vibration and
like the general resonance of people
when you're of a similar frequency you
tend to like you tend to attract the
kind of people that you're like
right so if you're really negative
you're probably gonna attract that kind
of person
if you're really positive you're going
to break attracting that kind of person
if you're positive yeah everybody
doesn't necessarily have that
and they want it they want it so there
are like
you know issues with optimism i mean i'm
definitely the most obvious person i
know in my family
and i always say i'm a lot more lucky
but i'm like i'm
crazy optimistic like i think this is
going to do this this is going to be
great
yeah and does it all happen most of it
doesn't happen
but it does happen to a certain extent
yeah i agree
and then i then i jump on that bridge
and it gets a little higher than the
last bridge
yeah so that it's not like it's all oh
i'm gonna
make a five million dollar profit on
that
and i ended up losing half a million
dollars well i've learned about how i
lost it and i still think there's
something there that i'm gonna like you
know that it might be a secondary
benefit of what was done
but i can't tell because i haven't made
that decision yet because i i'm not in
the water
so you've got to get in there or maybe
that needed to happen to get me to this
other place with this other partner
because that's actually who i'm supposed
to be but i had to get started and i've
had that happen
i'm in the middle of having it happen
right now really it's been it's been
looking me in the face
for 10 years and i wasn't ready for it
okay
what is it well i'm doing a business
transaction that i wasn't ready to do 10
years ago but i should have been 10
years old
but had i done it 10 years ago i'm
certain it would have happened correctly
yeah
you weren't really for what i want it to
be which is a much
i have a much clearer picture of it now
and then
i was bummed that i couldn't do it and i
was like
what's missing what's missing was me i
was missing i was missing the picture
i just had a little you know i was
looking at like to a small set of
glasses
now i have a bigger picture and i
understand like thank god i
do that so do you believe in manifesting
then i don't
i don't i i haven't really thought of it
and like i don't like
trying to say okay well this is
definitely that i just think that
you definitely get what you put into
something and you
definitely don't get everything you put
into something you know far
less so you're always going to be
putting in more but at the end of the
day it should be a definite it should be
a positive
positive addition every day to something
and some days you put in so much when
you get out so literally like
yeah there's gonna be a better way it's
gotta be easier and it isn't easier
it isn't this is not easy why why should
it be easy there's no easy
it's just real i agree anything
that's worth it as in like a business
or um emotional growth
uh you know personal growth with issues
you have
anything really worth it is hard it's
it's
it's it breaks you down
it it it
it proves it makes you test your love
for something really and it makes you
makes you makes you have to be committed
but
man i mean anything that i've ever
experienced that's really a great
transition has always been difficult
whether it's been about
my job and you know even retiring i mean
look that was a mouse 36
so you know that's a young age to retire
so
think about it um and uh and so that was
a tough decision but
uh on the other side of it i i
optimistically thought
i don't yes it's scary at first but then
imagine i i imagine if it's what if it's
something that i can't even imagine what
is that good what if it's uh and you
have to make space for new
so people are really afraid of change
people are afraid of letting something
go and i believe that
i have this theory that it's not the
change that they're actually scared of
it's the absence of something yeah it's
right it's the death of something so
it's the death we're mourning so
whether it's a relationship or a house
or um a business or something that
you've fixated your mind on that's going
to be real and you've dreamt way into it
um it's the death of it that is the
challenge
that makes people paralyzed from change
versus
because change is probably for the good
right like we're we're you're not making
a change unless you think it's for the
good
you're not it's going to change anyways
everything's changing anyways whether
you're going to like work with it or not
or like find your own way but i
i think you know i get asked the
question what would you do if you
weren't doing this
and i'm like well there's a difference
between what i like to do and what i'm
good at
i love to play the piano i love to play
golf i'm really good at
cooking and running restaurants and
businesses i'm i'm not a golfer
i couldn't do on a professional tour but
i think i am i think i'm that level i
have equipment like that
play those same courses what do you play
i play golf you know what do you play
with clubs
oh i have a set of uh taylormade's i had
uh i just got fitted for i'm getting
another set of
euros but i love the game in in a
in a cerebral way
historical love for it's like it's like
a warm blanket i just love it i love
everything about it
golf has so many analogies to life like
even just the simple one of
there's you can never win at golf
because winning it like the ultimate win
of golf is a hole in one in every hole
never happening it's never happening but
what i was saying what i was getting to
is like
um you have to realize what you're good
at and what you love
and what is going to work for you so
yeah i can't advise what's going to
happen in the future so if i ask my kids
what do you want to do
i can't think that that's up to them
they're being hit with so much stuff now
that i was never hit with but my kids
are smarter at 5 10 and
12 than i ever was near that level it's
the sophistication of what's out there
does it mean
that they're better or smarter it means
that there's a there's a smartness
and a street smartness of savvy they
have that they
have um because the internet everything
they can load a sort of access
quicker but it doesn't mean they're
going to be as successful and be able to
do a business and
deal with people and talk to people i
think we're getting less away from that
sort of interactional face with all
these
all this you know sitting on an iphone i
mean i was
i i'm shocked i was i go to these
conferences all the time and i go
i speak at like advertisement uh at
homes and all that and
i just watch before everything starts
people at a table like six people at a
table and no
it's a talking joke it's just like this
it's like you know they're right next to
each other and they're actually
texting each other and it's kind of like
okay i get it it's a really good device
because we can communicate
more communication usually means the
better but it's very hard that
interpersonal stuff is very hard you
know what scares the [ __ ] out of me
ai yes it does it does and it should be
very helpful because it's going to make
things better
medically i think you know it's going to
help people get
more sick at well quicker but i think
that if i had to tell people what would
they do
i would advise them to go live in a
different city every five years
like starting wherever you want not new
york and then go live and then have kids
too it doesn't matter doesn't matter
yeah yeah have the kids
pack up every five years go to paris and
they can go to live in brazil then go
live
probably the best thing i ever did to
grow up was live in england for three
years
and then find out what it the world is
about and then pick a town you want to
settle in
and you know as you spend even two years
five or six cities it is such an
education it is so cool
it's so it's so will glorify what life's
about first of all
it calms you down because you know that
the grass isn't greener on the other
side
it's just grass looks better maybe
it's greener maybe it's not greener
maybe it's different fed differently
but it's the same we live in the same
planet and we're the same people who set
different customs but yeah
that calms people down that makes you
kind of be a better person yes she
understands
yeah so that's what i would i would love
my kids yeah
well at least travel i mean i heard a
statistic like only eight percent of
americans have a passport it's
frightening
i mean i've gone through passport books
you can get on a plane right now
for 15 bucks you go to london you know
people i i made this post on instagram a
while back and it was like earth
like earth day or world day or something
like that and i was talking about i said
something about
uh having been to i just got this app
that a friend showed me had it's called
like
ben b and
um it just you can put what countries
you've been to what continents and then
the countries within and so
and it shows the percentage of the world
that you've been to based on how many
countries you've been to
and it's like i've traveled a ton but
it's like 12 percent
and it's like nothing and i've traveled
a ton
and i posted that i'd been to you know
49 states or and
31 countries and blah blah blah blah
blah
and you know i said get out there and
see the world you know it's
it's a beautiful place and cultures are
beautiful and other food is so amazing
and
just the different you know the little
differences that we find
within like the cultures and the rituals
and the routines that they have
whether it's barcelona eating at
midnight or whether it's
you know um you know new york city not
sleeping because the horns are going all
night whatever it is like it's just
it's very interesting out there and the
responses that all came back
were you know there's some positive in
there but people are like you know
wow how about get a real job you know
work in the world for real then you'll
find out you can't travel you can't go
anywhere and all i kept thinking was
that is exactly where you're gonna stay
because you can
travel for so cheap it's so easy
make a damn plan i mean you make a damn
plan
every 18 months you go someplace you
save up and you go
you know if you say you go stop going to
starbucks it's six bucks
a coffee right every day i i mean
i agree people always ask me if i wanna
go i'm like i got coffee at home
for a great weekend somewhere that's it
all you have to do is skip starbucks
or you know yeah i know right something
okay right yeah exactly with whipped
cream
and then this is expensive it is
expensive yeah yeah or stop stop buying
your lululemon leggings you know and
your sweatpants
like i said as parents you have to
understand that we don't know what's
going to happen for our kids
we we think we know best for them so our
job is to really make sure they're
prepared
they're respectful they're happy yeah
they understand
um manners they understand like things
you don't do they understand
modesty yeah and then at 18 hopefully
yeah you got enough experiences like
enough common sense well enough
library up here like you know this is
not what i was now i was raised
i'm gonna pass and they have enough like
enough dignity self-confidence
self-confidence
that's that's all we really can do then
they're their own i mean they're they're
running the minute they come out
it's not yours it's an interesting time
for kids because there's so much reason
there's so much going on to try and
build people's confidence to be
themselves and be who they are
but there's so much to tear it down and
it's all
instagram's fault no it's not
there's so many things i mean it's it's
just that we're all trying to put out
there our best self
right i'm not going to post a picture of
me that's ugly right if i have a choice
of a photo
i'm going to do the best job i can you
know but there are people that have gone
to the extreme of like
you know completely photoshopping things
whether it's their face or their body
and here's what i think here's my theory
is i don't want you to be disappointed
when you meet me
i hope you meet me and go yeah yeah
my mom order
expectations i now tell people yeah like
just
under promise and overperform and you
probably probably will have a very good
way about you yeah and be really
successful at
you know doing things the right way
because it's great to set the bar high
yeah but if you don't feed on the earth
it's not it's not going to happen for
you and you're going to disappoint
people and you disappoint people over
and over again
they're going to think something's wrong
and there's nothing wrong with you like
really not like
you're not planning how to do things
correctly
so what's um what is your i mean this is
a really typical question i don't really
love cliche questions but i think that
you know i think you're going to give me
a deep enough answer like based on our
conversation today
what is your definition of success wow
uh well it starts really at basic stuff
i think that a family
a strong family is a very big issue for
me
i have a strong family it's not a
perfect family
it's a strong family we definitely are
a group or we're tied together so that
to me is a big
pillar of success uh the ability to work
i mean the ability to get up every
morning and still have
drive and have ambition i
can't live without work i can't think
without work i'm not
not the worst thing for me to do is the
idol i don't want to be on vacation i
mean
which i work on vacation too but i mean
idol is titledness i love work i think
work is a blessing
so that to me is very work in the family
and those are
too big successful as far as
the money the financial i used to think
money was everything well everybody did
right
yeah some people still think it's
everything when they grow up yeah
uh to me i have no desire to have
what you know i don't need a lot of
watches or car i don't have one car
you have a car in new york city
revolutionary
yeah and really watching each other's
back
and one of my other successful pillars
is my wife watches my back
yeah that's true and i mean and then
a little cash on top of that is nice but
it really
if you have those three things you're a
rich person yeah
i mean look here's what i've i feel is
that if you're doing things that you
love
you're probably doing them well and the
money follows
it does i
like something gets figured out there's
been miraculous stories where people
have
these thoughts about like i need this
like like you know and then
search oddly enough they open up a check
and something in the mail comes and it's
the exact amount that they need and it's
like
just yes think about what you want not
what you don't want
i get up every day can i go to work
shitty days good days
the day i declared bankruptcy when i've
got the workers in the paper still it
might
be on google me it's still online it's
about our business
and people go bankrupt and you know and
it's like
it's one of those things people oh why'd
you go back like well you know we made
some mistakes
so on that day i went up and i actually
we actually put with lunch i was
when we i remember being at my good
friend jared keller and i were
having lunch at the uh polo bar
uh up in beverly hills we were there for
a
business transaction with such and uh we
were sitting here in lunch and i had a
phone call from one of my parties he
said
we're closing out of business today it's
like okay
all right have a good day
yeah i love you
what are we gonna do [ __ ] happens yeah
no
did i not go the next day i think like
you'll figure it out we're gonna figure
it out how are we gonna recover what's
the what's
what's this action steps how we're gonna
import the staff how we're going to
inform the public what's going to happen
but at the end of the day i never forget
that like we ordered a bottle of
champagne
because you just have to understand that
we learned so much from that failure
it was a success until it wasn't and
part of the reason why it wasn't a
success is because
a lot of reasons we learned that the
deal we entered into didn't have enough
control that we had into it
as we went into the deal we needed more
control and we couldn't push the levels
we had to push and
that business could only go so far
because of the so it's actually our
fault
if you wouldn't go back 10 years ago
most importantly you learned
i learned it was all false we never
wrote another document or another
business plan
yeah yeah but at the end of the day
and you knew they were newman which is
just you know great everything around
you
and everything we have in your life your
car your home
every vegetable you eat everything is a
product of failure
this took millions of dollars to perfect
yeah
if you look back at the factory they
have the chairs the original this is the
prototype this is the drawing
yeah there was failure failure failure
and now it's this but all everyone talks
about is this
there's so many great quotes about
failure about you know i'm thinking of
like i can't remember it but it's a
michael jordan one about shoot you know
shooting and
how many he missed or something like
that and it's like but he's michael
jordan
and you know you think about uh you
think about artists you think about
songs
like oh they're just so famous every no
not every song's a hit
a small percentage you know so it's like
you have failures it's reality and you
have to set yourself up for those
failures correctly say okay we're going
to go through a few product
changes it's not going to work what
works let's keep
let's keep going yeah and if you just
stop at the first failure
you're never ever going to sure you have
to look at your life like that too
or blaming or you're like learning or
your
relationships or you know what you eat
yourself
you're gonna fail it's gonna be okay and
stop blaming others
look at yourself absolutely and turn the
mirror i tell people
take responsibility if someone says i
can't do this i'm on a fixed income i
say who fixed it
yeah it's just an idea it's
it's like you gotta get through it but
you gotta wake up every morning and go
to work so
that's my idea of success amen all right
let's do something fun at the end here
um thank you no not quite
i want to learn about cuisine a little
bit better
okay and um i read that you said there's
like nothing you can't make
which i love i love the confidence i
feel similar on
a really remedial level so um
it's like a cuisine quiz so
name the cuisine the you know
where it's from whatever it's mexican or
ethiopian
or whatever it is that fits this
this category the hottest or spiciest
food
the hottest or well there's lots of
lots of um
cuisines that have hot or spicy food uh
do you ask me a continent or just like a
is it um
you know is it is it mexican is it uh
that i have had sure uh i've had some
killer spicy stuff in vietnam
i've had some stuff that blow your mind
in thailand
so i would say those one of those yeah
countries that's inter i've never i mean
i haven't ever had either of those so
i'm already being educated
okay what um is there one that's the
most time-consuming
oh without question french
french cuisine it's also the most
beautiful and the most
if you're gonna learn to cook yeah you
get larusquestra make you get all these
books are like
tones right they're bibles they're
biblical
verses of how things start and then how
they function and then there are
classifications of what they are
and then when you're making a pheasant
you go pheasant on the glass google
array you go
on the glass line and do blurry you look
it up so you have it's scripture so it's
encyclopedic wow so every word means
something but when you learn all the
words you know what it is
yeah and everything is it's like a
language yes it's fantastic
so that's like french french for me
i mean yeah maybe italian yeah i think
so medici
supposedly brought a lot of this to
france's all these questions you know
same marco polo chinese pasta thing
people have
you know where it came from but french
cuisine is probably
the most sophisticated most organized
okay
uh what's the sweetest
wow american breakfast no i
we're 300 years old yeah
i would say a lot of the southern
hemisphere like south america
mexico
[Music]
really yeah heavy heavy sweet desserts
i don't know why what uh what's the
easiest
like just like if you're just gonna be
like what's the easiest cuisine like oh
that's uh
yeah that's straightforward most
straightforward use of ingredients
it's probably italian yeah yeah because
um not that it's the easiest to
to learn it's the easiest to replicate
sure right sure so just dip between
knowing something and replicating it
let's call it accessible then it's
accessible it's very accessible
so it's very ingredient driven but
there's a few ingredients and it's very
the steps are easy okay but it's all
about the product
yeah yeah well look there's always some
fat
it's always you know i've never been to
italy but
you know hearing about people go to
italy and and eat italian which is
they're like it was so simple it was
just pasta but it was amazing you know
and you're like
there's magic
[Music]
i mean this might be the most along the
lines of time-consuming but what is the
hardest cuisine
is there the one that's the most
complicated
well i don't know a lot of that but
things about a lot of cuisines like
japanese cuisine
is extraordinarily meticulous in its
educational needs so in other words yeah
yeah
so i would probably say the most exact
thing and difficult to learn is japanese
yeah i have no idea yeah i'm not like
that
umami world is like it's the animal
world
i can appreciate it
um yeah okay what's the uh
what's the best pantry dependent this is
for like the person at home that
is like what's the most what's the
easiest to have nothing in the house
kind of but we're like what's the best
pantry dependent
meal canned food yeah there is great
canned food and there's average canned
food
there is
if you go to portugal or spain they have
restaurants they'll open up a can of
mussels or a can of anchovies and they
can bread
and they and it's okay because it's
sealed at its perfect state
right i mean that's what they say about
frozen stuff too they're like look it's
it's some of it is harvest is harvested
exactly at the right time
and i would say what would i buy i spend
most of the money in the pantry
because the stuff that goes it goes
[Music]
what's the next uh what's the cuisine on
the rise
on the rise you know they're always on
the right they go down
they come bubble back up you know every
20 years oh you've described a
food as being like fashion going in
cycles is it 30-year cycles just like
fashion well what's happening
they adopt every 20 years a couple of
more spices like gokujang
korean is very big now it's great
vietnamese is big
uh mexican thank god it's big so
it's bubbled up but it's come back in a
different form but it's added on like a
couple of like nice
accessories so right now what's
happening in the world
between uh new french bistros and
between new american
and old italian you're seeing a lot of
great
spin-offs of things and i love what's
happening
right now because it's getting more
rustic
but yeah more product driven
yeah i love that more integrity of the
ingredients and
sourcing and more focus i
a restaurant with a always small menu
that you just do this you cannot be
everything to everybody just be yourself
open a
small joint first and specialize in one
thing and kill it
and kill it and you will be on the map
in no time at all
are you ready said you're a life coach
you shouldn't be 100 restaurants
in the airports doing the most
incredible whatever
small and 10 restaurants that spend so
much money you don't make any money on
their
such headaches they have all these
employees and they're making everything
for everybody
and kind of satisfying everybody it's
really hard really hard to do
all right what's your least favorite
what's your least favorite cuisine
that's a hard question to ask for me
because i you have to eat everything
but if you say what i don't eat a lot of
is fried food wait i'm not like faster
yeah
yeah i'm mean either like i look at it
and i think it's fake food to be honest
correction we've had french fries
no burger king no none of that you know
what they have no desire
so if they want if they want a ice cream
sundae i'll make one
they want a cheeseburger i'll make
cheeseburgers it's like when someone
wants something
yeah i'm like oh yeah we'll go to jj
mills
yeah hopefully we want a really good ice
cream to go i'm with you i
found a little laboratory in gelato
we'll get to make it right in front of
you
eat real food we eat real food we don't
do fast food
it's garbage and you know what we'll say
is sugar
when you look at the the nutritional
content of something simple like a
burger
you know or like gosh what was those
mcgriddles with
i mean just there's sugar in the bun
like a chicken i mean it's ridiculous
they smell terrible too like if it's
ever in your family
like sugar yeah like the wonder why 40
americans are addicted yeah and it yeah
yeah it's it's it's um my
my moment was many years ago when um
taco bell was advertising
that they were now going to be 33 real
me
i'm like you're bragging about that
it's terrible okay and then what's your
most favorite like give me give me your
favorite give me your favorite cuisine
like favorite meal
this is your this is your final meal
for lunch i'm going for lunch i'm gonna
go and have italian
yeah anything spelling gives it a
justice i love
yeah yeah it's not about a cheat meal
it's not like a bad meal it's like
what's your favorite
grilled fish in the summer with a glass
of rose
three to four what times a day times a
week that's what i would
go to so i need to send you some of my
rose then
i make wine you're kidding yeah i'm out
in napa
you do the 18 is amazing too it's so
it's made from the cab grapes so it's
the bleed off so it's
real yeah yeah thank you let's drink
some rose together
okay done thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today i
hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button